oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
hi everyone my name is philip
i'm senior producer on dead space with
me here today is roman campos ohio the
creative director on the project hello
everyone
all right let's get started
so what we're about to do today is a bit
unorthodox for us at ea
we're going to give you with this live
stream a first look at some very early
and i'll say very very early footage
very very very uh
footage from the game
but we wanted to do this because we want
to be open with the communication and
open about how we're tackling this game
however i want to be clear this is not a
gameplay reveal we're not going to be
showcasing very long sections of the
game of the wonderful chapters
we want to give you all an early look at
the game that we're making to be able to
see reactions across the community about
the game that we're making
and there's two reasons why we want to
do that
first at motives one thing that we that
really is important for us is that we
want to create a game that excites
players um and i think that sars
quadrants was actually a great example
of this
it came from
the the nostalgia that the team had over
the x-wing versus tie fighter franchise
and it carried through in the experience
that they created
and it's a little bit what we want to do
for dead space
we see this project and we want to make
sure that we're honoring the legacy that
we stay true to the source true to the
original
and for us the best way to do that is to
engage with the community early on to be
able to give you first look into inside
like behind the curtain and see the game
that we're making and and be able to
think uh to see how we're tackling it
and we've actually been doing this since
the very beginning of the project um we
got in contact during the conception
phase with the community council that we
created some hardcore dead space fans
that remain active even after years
of inactivity for that death-based
franchise
and
with this community council we've
established a relationship where we gave
them first look at
some of the executive presentations that
we were making with an ea some of the
creative brief game design documents
first
playable footage of the game
and in exchange we asked them brutal
feedback like what are we making is it
good is it what fans expect out of this
remake what is it
where does it suck most importantly
and for this live stream today we're
actually thrilled to have two of the
community council members with us
joining us so uh we have jackie butler
and khalif adams joining us for this
live stream hello jackie hi khalif oh
are you oh my hi phil hi roman we're
doing great very excited to be here
excited to see you both seeing that
you're all hanging out in montreal
looking good i see they got you all made
up looking cute i love it i appreciate
it uh i'm kylie fathoms one of the hosts
or the host of the spawn on me podcast
i'm super excited to be here i'm a huge
dead space fan i've been waiting for
this for a very long time and uh i get
to rock with one of my favorite content
creators on the planet jackie let the
folks at home know a little bit more
about you
hello everyone my name is jackie butler
i'm a cardiac nurse extern soon to be rn
as well as a streamer and content
creator here on twitch
let me tell you khalif roman
there's very few games that i wish i
could experience for the first time
again one of those is obviously dead
space so i'm literally over the moon to
be here no pun intended you know what
i'm saying so let's get straight into it
and talk about the dead space we make
all right let's get started so we're
gonna dive right in with the classic
dark and claustrophobic headbanger
hallway shown here on the screen is what
dead space looked like in 2008 although
revolutionary for its time let's see the
design process and how it looks now
roman and phil can you show us more
yeah so actually one of the first things
that we did was we went back to the
legacy assets for the game
so we want to recreate with the proxies
the full ship the ishimura to recreate
it and then our art team went in and
started an added level of details to the
environment so that we could have a
higher fidelity and start seeing
what can the game look like on next
generation of consoles
so we went in added details then started
working on the shaders and the materials
to try to have that metallic look
that we we were after and just like to
get the right materials out in the
environment
from there we did like a first pass at
lighting to try to get the mood right
because the atmosphere of dead space is
pretty much on lighting and then on the
effects
to try to get like that full picture
of
what are we after what are we trying to
achieve for the game
and
it looks great on on a few stills but it
actually looks way better in game
so so what type of engine did you guys
use to create this and what graphics are
you aiming for
so great question jackie we're using
frostbite as our dev engine
uh and we're we're going for obviously
um in graphics eye infidelity and our
focus is on
lighting the effects uh and just overall
audio experience to make sure that we
would deliver the right atmosphere
something that was key to an original
game
yeah so i know we have a real live
functional build currently can you
bring that up
and this again is a work in progress
so yes that's super early like it's
end of pre-production build we're just
starting production so it's really
really really far from from being done
but
one thing we really want it and you
touch about it it's really wanted to
make sure that we nail the ambience and
not only the look the lightings the vfx
the fog but also
nail that ambience give you the feeling
that you're in the shimmer you're inside
those dark corridors and
not only it's in engine it's actually in
game and here's my boy isaac so
that rig that's ammo it's not the
original it's
a new one it's still working progress
it's gonna be improved a lot but it
gives it first taste at isaac clark in
in the remake and look here we are wow i
mean the lighting everything looks
phenomenal
the smoke
it looks so good
very much what we should be expecting at
this point from next generation graphics
it's really dead space but like you
never saw it i think
so it has been almost 13 years you know
since the original game came out
original dead space why is this remake
happening now and what is what exactly
is this remake can you elaborate on that
so
one thing that's important for us and
that's why it's for
ps5 xbox series or for or for pc is that
there is no it's not about one thing
like dead space is a super strong
experience and so it's really about
improving on a lot of different elements
to create that
that original but still new experience
whether it's the new lighting and
retracing whether like phil mentioned
it's about audio whether it's
improvements to gameplay and having new
zeal as you're gonna see maybe later
improvements and dismemberment and how
you actually do the damage to the
enemies whether it's about having an
unbroken and continuous experience it's
about doing a lot of improvements and
how we enrich that experience and so
that's really what that remake is about
yeah because you know we have been
looking at reddit we've been looking
online and there has been some people in
the community noting that you know the
game already stood the test of time this
is still considered to be quote unquote
a perfect game
exactly and so
like like we show like i mentioned
what's what's really important for us
it's to capture that uh that original
ambience that original experience
that like you've never experienced
before and that's really the age where
we're after i believe yeah and i
mentioned it earlier like we're we want
to make sure that we're honoring the
legacy that's one of our production
pillars that we have for the game uh but
at the same time
we want to make it relevant for today
like the games have evolved a lot since
the original dead space came out
from
obviously graphics which is like the
easiest way to see how how it changed uh
but also as far as systems just
necessarily too much
to make sure
but but as far as systems as far as as
just opportunities for gameplay um and
how to leverage it that's something that
uh we think that
given the evolution that that space had
within its own uh franchise with that
space two in that space three but also
how the franchise uh how just the game
industry evolved
uh outside that space there's
opportunities for us to make a a
better uh or more complete experience
let's say yeah i'm just blown away at
how how good everything looked from from
just even that small glimpse into the
into the engine it feels like you know i
know you're saying it's really really
early it's really really early but it's
just yeah this is
my goodness what is what is it going to
look like when you wind up getting kind
of further down the line so that's
really fantastic
we might keep some surprises
so can you please now show the stack
comparison of the original 2008 game
versus the current
project
yeah that's a massive difference you
know you remember
your favorite game in a certain way and
you think that it looks great but then
when you see improvements it's it's wow
big difference big big difference
yeah it's it's always interesting to see
just how far we've come in terms of
technology right like we it was only 13
years ago but it seems like we've gone
some leaps and bounds where we're able
to kind of take it all the kind of small
details you're seeing on on the the
newer model of isaac is really is really
fantastic this season
uh what are your current goals for the
remake exactly how are you going to
honor the legacy of dead space because
that is huge shoes to fill
bars so high
yeah it it is definitely a and and
like the team is actually extremely
passionate uh
we're referencing a lot to the original
game um having a lot of looks at it um
and
like i said by making it relevant we're
looking at different games and what they
did and see how can we bring it back
inside uh inside that space so like one
of the example is something that we're
trying to do is to have an unbroken
experience to make the game fully
seamless and how can that create an
experience where where the players more
even more immersed within the game um
that was previously the case and it's
really one of the big objectives that we
have for for that game is that
from even before the start screen
till the end of the game the rolling
credits to never have any break of
experience to have that full and
uninterrupted sequence shot and so
that of course has a lot of impact on
what we're building and just starting
with all the ishimura and the structure
of the game is built because we don't
want any cut so there should be no
loading i'll do the full ship should be
walkable from end to end seamlessly etc
there's a lot of elements that start to
unfold when you start to think the game
that length of really unbroken emotion
and like really from from the get-go
like we
we gave ourselves an objective like if
if possible could we have players
wanting to take the controller and play
for 12 hours straight not never putting
them down not even going to the bathroom
just because they were so immersed
within the game
and that's what we're after that's like
the type of immersion that we want to be
able to achieve
that's going to be a back of the box
quote you can't go to the bathroom on
the back of the box
i appreciate it but i also heard you
talk about you know how you want to
double down on or at least really focus
in on what makes dead space fantastic
around the horror aspect
of the game too i'd love to hear more
about that
so of course aurora it's uh it's one of
the
of the main pillar of of that space and
it's it's about a lot of elements in
that space so of course the story it's
about about that it's that iconic uh
survival or story you're alone trapped
on the on that earthing spaceship but
the main element for us was to get the
ambience right and so that's why we
started with uh with elements like for
example the bengal corridor or the
workshop that you can see in in the
teaser is to make sure
that we capture the indians it's it's
about more than just the gore or the
monsters or the story or the character
it's really about
the ishimura and how isolated and
stressed
you feel when you're inside that ship
and so that's really an important pillar
for us and so that's why we want you to
be fully immersed and to never be able
to pull out from uh from that experience
the pacing was so good like it was a
master class in piecing the original
dead space
to keep you on the edge of your seat all
the time and that's actually something
that that we challenged the team early
on like how can we make sure that we
don't break that recipe that we don't
break um the right amount of nothing
happening that's going to actually
increase the level of tension when
you're playing
and so far the team's been taking that
challenge and doing an amazing job at it
and it's always something that's at the
back of our head uh in every review that
we're doing uh and
they're delivering amazing work on it
it's one of the thing it's how can we
keep players constantly on the toes and
we might have some surprise coming on
that and on how much you can be
surprised even when you're doing
something
it's a lot of fun
so what would the stream be without
necromorphs isn't that what we are
really here for
when we say cut off their limbs you know
we want you to experience every gory
detail of dismembering iconic
necromorphs now we will showcase our
dismemberment jim the dev team has
created a peeling system that will be
implemented into combat
would you mind telling us more about the
original system versus the new system
and what peeling actually means
i think actually something that's very
important
as you can see with the feet like it is
definitely a gym
and it's intentional that we showcase
this in a gym
because
we're so early with it
visually we're not at the right level of
quality where we want to achieve
but we want to showcase functionality
here that's what we want to talk about
and what is the system that we have in
mind for peeling like you said
so obviously
same thing it's a really early build
it's a gym everything that you see is
working progress it's first
implementation a lot of vfx are missing
a lot of those modalization are not
final and the singular thing like flash
tiering etc but one thing that is
important for us and i just show its
first
of course dismemberment is back and it's
back
with all the depth and and fun you can
have in that space but one thing we
wanted to uh and those are the only
things there's those other things you
can see only on that place
[Laughter]
one of the the thing we wanted to
improve uh about uh about that
experience it's when you're using a
weapon that is not a carving weapon like
something not like the plus market on
plasma color is really fun to use you
can just shoot at anything and really
you have that instant feedback of the
limb getting killed etc but when you had
a different weapon knowing how much
damage you were dealing to the enemy how
was you reacting etc it was
not necessarily as visceral and as clear
as the original device so that's the
thing we're working on at the moment and
we call peeling it's basically
that body destruction technology that
we're developing
that
is allowing us to really
remove
so at the moment the flesh out of the
the bones of the enemy and to give you
a good sense not only of
gore and aurora and ambiance but also of
how much damage am i getting to that
opponent is my weapon actually
useful against this one how close
is it to die and
that's something for me that is really
interesting and so when we were speaking
about
why doing a remake and where can we
improve
those are
an example of what we can do is that we
don't have any more to choose which
feature we actually want to push we can
have dismemberment we can have much more
precision and body destruction we can
have seamless loading for the for the
wall ship etc etc and that's something
really really interesting for us
and another thing that is actually
really interesting is that system so
again for the moment it's really early
at the moment you're only showcasing it
on the on the naked slasher so you only
see it with the the flash but
of course later it's gonna support like
uh the claw body armor or different
layers weak points etc but it also
improved one of the core
of shooting in that space which is
around the precision and not only the
precision of my weapon but as an example
the precision of the plasma cutter and
so
if i was to shoot let's say on that leg
then
if i'm shooting here i'm not going to
cut the leg because i'm not shooting at
the place where the bone is actually
visible if i need to if i want to cut
that leg now i need to be much more
careful and precise
in my aiming and in the shooting and
then for us what is interesting is that
it opens a whole new layer
of uh of shooting and combat loop where
you can have some weapons that are
better at carving through the enemies
somewhere that are better at cleaning
them sorry for the mic
some weapons that are better at cleaning
the at cleaning the enemy and removing
the flesh and the tissue etc and that's
something really really interesting for
us anytime roman speaks about this
memory but he gets overly passionate and
expressive
[Music]
even with the team internally uh he
shows a lot of passion in that topic so
yeah i can just imagine you being on the
phone and talking to somebody who's like
yeah we need to get more body
dismemberment and more destruction on
the body and people just like what the
heck is he talking about it looks great
sometimes sometimes
there's weird moments like that in the
gym where you you do a meeting about
dismemberment and blood and gore and
dead bodies and you misspell somebody's
name and you're inviting somebody else
to that meeting that is not part of the
team and they go like oh no
brace yourself strap in
so so roman on what level can we expect
the detail of filleting necromorphs
essentially
how detailed are we talking here
in terms of the body destruction the
peeling it's going to be really super to
tell us we can see on that video so
that's
the first first steps of that technology
if the video is playing which is not i
think
at the moment
yes here we go
you can see that it's really super
precise it's exactly where you're aiming
where you're shooting it's exactly
respecting the shape of the of the
projectile at the enemy uh if it was
fire you would see it going through the
through the body of your enemy and
burning and burning the flesh etc it's
the peeling the
that cut that body destruction system is
going to be super precise in term of
pure dismemberment and then where you're
able to uh to cut the necromancer slims
here where we want to improve it because
we feel like characters like the slasher
for example
it was already really deep in terms of
gameplay like they are different
behavior based on whether you were
cutting the legs or the head where they
go berserk etc so here our goal it's for
enemies like slasher it's not
necessarily to improve or make or give
more precision where you cut you can cut
the enemy it's more to try to extend
that fun and that depth to other enemies
that tend to be a bit lighter in terms
of of dismemberment and behavior like
for example the infector or the brute
like i can't wait to show you when you
get behind the brute and you start to
peel his back
that's the type of improvement we're
going for
get to the get to the weak points
yeah i love the peeling of the different
layers of skin down to the organs and
bones especially coming from a medical
background it's just insane to see uh
the level of expectation is very much up
here and you know we'll hold you
accountable
one thing that you you might have
noticed quickly in the in the prototype
and that's something we are we're going
uh we want to experience a bit more we
want to dig a bit more it's when you
actually cut
a limb but there's still a layer of
flesh
we don't necessarily always want the
limb to go out and and fly away and
sometimes we keep it attached by the the
layer of flesh or tendrils to the
to the body so currently that vfx is
missing but the technology to keep it
attached and dangling is there and so
you can grab those with uh with kinesis
to
to make it a bit faster to dismember
them and then you can throw them back to
the opponent i think we'll speak a
little bit more about kinesis after but
that's also the the power and uh and
weapon synergy loop that's also
something we want to try to
to improve uh in the dead space roommate
yeah yeah by bringing it back like uh it
it gives you an option to
we actually took back the the impalement
from that space too so it gives you an
option to actually impale your enemies
that's right in front of you and using
it as a projectile against your enemies
so so it gives you more creative
opportunities uh to to kill your enemies
really so that so that means that we're
gonna go from we're gonna continue to
have cut off your limbs we're going to
have dangle your limbs too
the thing that people are going to start
screaming in the chat pretty soon
um
one of the other you know you talked
about you know how some of these uh
pieces of tech are adding to the
improvements of
of what this remake is going to wind up
being i'd love to hear you kind of talk
a little bit more about
you know some some other improvements
that we've seen not only in scale in
terms of you know rooms that we've seen
before we saw the headbanger room a
second ago but i want to dig into and
let's let's pull up the zero g therapy
room which i think
also showcases this kind of next layer
of where you're thinking about going
from an improvements perspective just
talk a little bit about you know
where you're kind of seeing this move we
see isaac kind of in the space right now
floating around the space uh probably
gonna show off some of his thrusters and
and stuff in a minute uh i'd love to
hear more about you know kind of where
you're thinking about in terms of
improvements in this layer too
so
for us really
going back to the original dead space
it was something that we felt so again
super early built that we felt we could
uh
we could actually improve in terms of of
experience and immersion it's the 0g
and how you would move around in 0g and
that's something that was really
good
and improving the experience in that
space 2 and 3 that we felt was really
missing in uh in the original dead space
and so
that's why we we took that mechanic of
of flying around when you're in zero g
and with much more 360 degree freedom
and now you can play that space and
really feel you're in space during uh
during those moments and so also that's
a mechanic
that we're starting to uh to improve a
bit on like for example you can interact
as as you fly around you can go into
tighter corridors those kind of things
but also it allows us to
revisit
some of the old contents and create
new ways to navigate new path like here
in the original you would have gone back
through that door
through where you came from and here it
allows us to create new environments
with eventually new challenges
to surprise also the people that know
the game and
will be like oh wait what's that
and no we're gonna surprise you
so so it's really delivering on the
fantasy of being in space making sure
that we're able to use that and
revisiting all the places in the game in
the original where
there was ziruji which was the superman
jump back in dead space one and now
applying full 360 motion
and finding ways to provide a real
challenge uh in this type of environment
and so far there's been very good ideas
like this one about how can we reach
reverse uh through the same environment
and provide something new for the
players so so we're definitely on the
lookout for these opportunities
when we
revisit
each of these
gameplay sections
yeah for me in the original game that
zero g jump was very disorienting i
don't know if anyone else agrees with
this but it made me very disoriented
seeing quality of life improvements
carried from two back into one with
thrusters and the movement is is
incredible that's a huge improvement as
is
you know it's funny
um the community quickly recognize and
decipher the morse code from the
ishimura in the original reveal that we
had people figured out right away
from the blinking flashing lights but
you know we didn't see any comments on
the subreddit or online about the
thrusters on isaac
[Laughter]
but no it's really interesting because
then also like i was mentioning it
allows us to
revisit to the to zero g areas
potentially create new ones and add a
whole set of of different challenges
challenges sorry in uh that were not
present in that space one that we can
now create or recreate because you have
all that freedom of motion
across that one big ship
there was also one question topic that
was uh prevalent throughout the
community that we saw time and time
again and that is the topic of
microtransactions you know they were
apparent in dead space three so at this
point can you please be transparent and
honest regarding microtransactions and
you know if that will make an appearance
in dead space one remake
so very very clear no micro transaction
not at all no no
already
in an interview i think yes no no don't
have that in the remake
that's awesome that's awesome that's
good to hear
i think everybody in this channel and
everybody in the game on the recall yeah
very it's on the right
that's what we want to hear okay
that's that's two back of the box quotes
that we've gotten for the stream already
that's easy easy
well well done
um we you know we've talked a lot about
you know the improvements things you
kind of want to transition ways you want
to improve not only the gameplay but all
the systems around it but i think one of
the things we haven't gotten a chance to
talk about
is the how do you want to enrich the
storytelling in this game as well
there's lots of different aspects to
that and i'd love to hear more thoughts
about how you're trying to broaden and
expand that as well
so about the the story and narrative as
a broader topic in
that space
first
we are not gonna change the foundation
of the story because that story is very
iconic and it's it's just a great a
great sci-fi horror story it's really
about being isaac
and going into that hulking spaceship
and feeling alone and diesel and
isolated as you try to survive all those
space zombies and stuff
and trying to find nicole trying to
solve that mystery about the marker
stuff all of those core themes of the
originals those are elements that not
only we really want to continue to to
have in the game but that we want to
build uh on top of the the the things
that we want to enrich in term of uh of
story or narrative it's really about the
the bigger universe of that space we
want to
have more ties with what came after
whether it's the books whether it's the
anime whether it's dead space 2 we want
to put back the original in a more
in a better way if i can say inside that
broader universe and
yes sometimes it can be through really
soul
message or
audio links or or messaging the
environment sometimes it will be a bit
more
and we can come to that later but also
one thing we wanted to make it's we
wanted to uh to build a bit more on on
some of the characters around the around
isaac whether it's a kendra or ammon and
one thing for me that's really important
in that space is
as isaac
in the story
you're looking for nicole but actually
in game
not so much as we can say so that's
something we want to improve we want
to give you the means to actually look
for and more than look for
learn what happens what happened to
earth during the outbreak that's one of
the elements that uh that we're gonna
not necessarily improve in the story but
enrich and that we want to add in the
law of the game
i'm excited for that again that's one of
those things where you know the world
building that you wind up doing through
the through the ship and and through
those small audio logs and you know the
way you kind of talked about you know
bringing up some of those those elements
into kind of a
next layer that we will be able to get a
chance to see
i i'm just hyped to see where that's all
going to land because it's just going to
be so cool to see what things when you
do that one-to-one comparison was like
oh that thing got changed
got added there um yeah i definitely had
same questions on like my first
playthrough and the many other times
it's like what about the marker what
exactly did happen to senior medical
officer nicole brennan uh i just want
more of a cohesive you know make us
whole narrative type situation which i
hope like i'm really hoping that you
guys deliver on this future game
you will be one of the first to know i
think
council privileges council privileges
um
one of the other and and kind of big
questions that a lot of folks
uh in the community have have been
wondering about i've been thinking about
and and hopefully you'll be able to give
us an answer on this one is
will isaac be voiced in this game
well that's the glass uh excuse me i
have something to
excuse me i have something to say
and it's been a long time coming
hi i'm gonna write and i'm excited to
announce that i'm reprising my role as
isaac clark for the remake of dead space
one
i want to thank all of you for allowing
me to give isaac a voice
i can't wait to suit up throw that rig
on and do my best to try to keep isaac
alive
although i've got a feeling some of you
might try to keep me from doing that
in the words of isaac clark
stick around
i'm full of bad ideas
and that's what i'm talking about that's
amazing gunner will be coming back uh he
has to he's isaac oh my god
he has no choice okay he has no choice
we we made him do it uh phil roman
share some thoughts on on gunner coming
back as as isaac
well actually it was one of the first
thing that we we discussed with the
council at the very beginning like it
was one of those open questions that we
had
the initial dead space there there was
obviously no voice for isaac um but that
was change uh for dead space two that
space three gunner played an amazing
part in this
and delivered a great performance to
create that character and so
for us it was really a question like
should we voice them for this remake or
not should we stay which is why like we
engage in that con
conversation with all the folks on the
council to try to see what from your
perspective
what was your opinion on this key topic
and
what was clear was that well if he's
back it has to be isaac uh it has to be
gunner isaac is gunner uh
and so
like we we started to have these
discussions with casting and it became
very very clear
rapidly that that for us that was the
right angle to tackle this topic
yes for me it's so first as a fan of
that space before even being on that
project
it was
yeah gunner is isaac and
revisiting that space one
amazing game and revisiting isaac for me
we needed isaac to be in that space one
and so that's why for me it was really
important and i was so happy to uh to be
able to uh to have him be isaac in in
that space one
but one thing that is really important
for us it's there is something
that is key
in the in the dead space
theme and ambience it's the isolation
you're alone
you're alone on that spaceship you're
alone facing those enemies you it's
really that feeling of being isolated in
the room and
sometimes hearing a voice
it fights against that like you know
you're going to the basement it's dark
and you're looking for the for the light
and you talk to yourself because it's
reassuring especially when you're alone
in the dark
and so that's something we didn't want
it to break
in that space and so isaac is only going
to talk one of the rules that we have is
that isaac is only going to talk
when he's being talked he is going to
respond he's going to engage with him
and he's going to engage with kendra and
so on he's going to be part of those
discussions but then
when he's alone
when you're alone in that dark corridor
he's not going to talk he's not going to
break that immersion he's not going to
break that feeling of isolation
but one thing that was important for us
for isaac as a character is
he's not a spaceman he's a really
specific type of character nothing is
isaac but also he's an engineer and so
we really wanted to give him
more a sense of being the main character
of that story giving more sense of
agency on what's going on and so
when there's a new objective when
there's a discussion about how are we
going to blow that barricade how old are
we going to restart the engine of the
ship
we wanted isaac to be part of that
discussion we wanted isaac to be part of
the solution he's the expert he's the
space engineer and so that's why also we
wanted to uh to give him a voice it's we
wanted to improve the character on the
on that perspective so here it is
back
couldn't be happier about that
he couldn't either
jackie any more thoughts about gunner
being back in the game
no i'm just i'm very excited i mean this
is expected the council very much told
you guys that that is exactly what we
wanted and i'm really glad that followed
through everything came through
very excited
yeah i i am hyped even though i did not
get the part it's okay gunnar we will
let you rock
uh as i hit this time around you know
that space to remake i will i will be
isaac at some point
you're a close second khalif close
second see this is why i love you i
appreciate this is this is again another
back of the box honest
again this is the reason why we do this
kind of work
um we're we're almost out of time but i
want to give you two gents a little bit
of time just to share again any last
thoughts you have with the folks here
watching the chat and everybody else out
in in the land who are who are dead
space fans right now
yeah well one thing like i said at the
beginning
the purpose for us to do this is to hear
your feedback hear your thoughts um so
so hopefully we've shown a few asset uh
we've talked about the game hopefully
that triggers some discussion that we're
able to to look and see uh and
understand what's important for the
community um so so that's really the
purpose for us
and we hope that the community is going
to engage
so that we can get that feedback back
and another important element really for
us is that
we've started a little bit less than a
year now on that project and
we start to have
some amazing things i think and uh it's
production it's just starting
and i'm incredibly amazed and
proud of everything the team is doing
like it's one of the most amazing team
i've worked with and i want to thank
them again and again for everything
they're doing and not only because
i do believe it's amazing but also
because it's really difficult time for
for building all of this thing in that
context of the body and for the pandemic
and working from all and all this thing
and so being able to see all these
assets all those arts the gameplay they
are building in that context i'm just
like wow i'm blown away like the team's
amazing thank you very much guys that
was a really beautiful concept art you
had on the screen there it was uh
medical
it was stunning i can't wait for
everyone to see that in the actual game
shipped yes this is so pretty i want
this the desktop background
right seriously i don't want to live
there but i want that as a piece of my
desktop for sure yeah
can you hook you up jackie we can help
you out nice uh jackie before we get up
out of here any last words for the folks
at home
well i you know i had a wonderful time
and i want to thank motive and ea
uh you know
for allowing khalifa and i to be a part
of this wonderful community thank you
roman and phil and you know also thank
you all the unsung heroes you know on
the dev team working hard to make this
ship
for the best possible thing you know but
thank you so much
yeah and i'll just end out and say again
you know phil and roman and the rest of
the team
you all are putting in such great work
uh to bring this game back to life in a
fantastic way i as a huge fan and
extremely excited to dangle their limbs
and do all of those things within that
game
uh and we hope that also our friends and
our and our compadres over in the
council as well we hope you did you
proud today uh everybody at home who's
watching the stream make sure you go
check out dead space twitter account you
can get some more updates when they go
live and again thank you so much for
being here today
take care and we'll see you
thanks a lot everyone thank you very
much bye
[Music]
you